welcome back a Russian course has found
the women's NBA star Brittany Greiner
guilty of drug possession and smuggling
she's been sentenced to nine years in
prison and will have to pay a fine well
let's go live now to the Russian capital
and to our Moscow correspondents Diana
Magna and Dinah what's she expecting a
sentence like this
Russian Justice is not known as being
particularly lenient and this judge
certainly proved themselves not to be
the prosecution had asked for nine and a
half years and what the judge handed
down was a nine-year sentence the
maximum that she could have got is 10
years and she had hoped that by pleading
guilty to having brought cannabis oil
into Vape cartridges into Russia but
without having had any intention of
doing that she said she packed in a rush
and by mistake she brought it in it's
legal in the U.S and she was prescribed
it medical marijuana for um to relieve
chronic illnesses pain from chronic
illness injuries that she had so she
said she bought it in accidentally that
she had no intent to break Russian law
but nevertheless the court has handed
down really quite a heavy sentence nine
years and a one million Ruble fine which
is about 13
000 pounds
um Brittany Greiner a few hours ago had
the opportunity to say a few final words
where she apologized hugely to her fans
to her family for what she said was an
honest mistake let's just take a listen
to what she said
my parents taught me two important
things one take ownership for your
responsibilities and two to work hard
for everything that you have
that's why I pled guilty to my charges I
understand
everything that's being said against me
the charges that are against me and that
is why I played guilty but I had no
intent to break any Russian laws
so what happens next it doesn't
necessarily mean that Brittney Griner
will go to jail for the next nine years
because already there is discussion of a
possible prisoner swap underway and
rather unusually the United States
Anthony blinken the Secretary of State
asked Russia to do a prisoner exchange
of Brittany Greiner and another U.S
national Paul Whelan who actually holds
British citizenship as well and Canadian
and Irish whether those two could be
exchanged for a notorious Russian arms
dealer who's been in a U.S jail for the
last 13 years Victor Boot and he's meant
to be serving 26 years now the Kremlin
is hit back saying that it doesn't want
these kinds of negotiations done in
public criticizing what it called
megaphone diplomacy but we understand
that there is quite a lot of intense
discussion going on behind the scenes
about how to get those two U.S Nationals
back we understand that Russia is asking
for it to be a more fair swap of two for
two rather than just Victor Boot and
there are various other names on the
table tables but as obviously this is an
incredibly tense time between us and
Russia so those negotiations are going
to be fraught but interestingly we did
see already in April
um another prisoner swap take place a
U.S marine exchanged for a Russian pilot
who'd been in a U.S jail for quite a
long time so I don't think hope is uh it
is gone for Brittany Greiner and for
Paul Whelan
um but I think there will be some pretty
intense discussions going on behind the
scenes for the next few weeks it's one
of those things that these prisoner
swaps happen and we won't know that they
are happening until they're done
um but there are certainly a lot of
families and fans especially a Brittany
Greiner who are hoping that that deal is
done absolutely
um Diana thank you very much that's
Diana magni they're our Moscow
correspondent well actually we've just
had some updates coming in now
um President Joe Biden has just uh
released a statement calling that
sentence a nine-year prison sentence is
unacceptable and he also goes on to call
on Russia to immediately release
Brittany Greiner who's just been
sentenced to nine years